and we want to bring you a little bit of
breaking news that's coming into sky
news at the moment and the queen has
tested positive for kovid the news
coming in from buckingham palace we know
that uh prince charles
uh tested positive uh for a second time
and that was along with the duchess of
cornwall
and they both isolated um
after that positive uh test after an
engagement in central london but we're
hearing that the queen has tested
positive the queen is uh
95 years old she's tested positive
we know that at the moment what we're
hearing is that her symptoms are mild um
but just to reiterate that breaking news
if you are just joining us uh that the
queen has uh she's tested positive for
kovid19
and she's experiencing
mild cold-like symptoms
we're hearing that she expects to
continue the lightest
of duties at windsor this week
we know prince charles also tested
positive along with
camilla
so we expect to hear a bit more from
buckingham palace as we go on but what
we do have coming into sky news is that
the queen has tested positive for
covid19 she will have medical attention
say the palace and she will obviously
follow
all appropriate guidelines that's coming
from the palace
we know that her symptoms are
mild
and cold-like
but we know that she has she's tested
positive for covid
and this i imagine
was that close contact that she may have
had with her son
prince charles who tested positive for
covid uh for the second time um all
symptoms we're hearing are mild at the
moment these are the last pictures uh
that we saw of the queen engaging um in
her first face-to-face um
duties in a while this was last week and
as you can see she looks well and she
looks she's very happy
but we're hearing in here at sky news uh
that the queen
has tested positive for uh kovid 19.
what we do know so far what we're
hearing from the palace is that her
symptoms are mild so cold-like she will
continue to carry out
the lightest of duties
uh from windsor next week and of course
as we get more information
on this uh breaking story uh we'll bring
them to you and uh just to repeat that
we knew didn't we we heard that news
prince charles
um tested positive for covid and he held
his first uh engagements didn't he after
that second bout of covid last week um
and what we were hearing from the palace
is in terms of prince charles and
camilla those symptoms were very mild
too
uh
we know that she is expected to
continue
light duties from the palace all of this
is coming from buckingham palace by the
way um that she will continue with very
light
duties we know that her symptoms as it
stands are very cold like
and she will continue with work we know
she is very diligent uh person and will
want to continue with whatever she can
continue to do we know that prince
charles said that he bounced back very
quickly from uh that second bout of
covid um and
we're hoping to hear more from from the
palace later but what we do know if you
are just tuning in to sky news uh this
morning buckingham palace say
that the queen has tested positive
for covert covid19
she will follow all procedures so
isolating
at windsor she will carry out some light
duties and she will have
medical attention around her given her
age uh they want to
you know make sure that this is a
precaution that she has this medical
care around her to keep an eye on her as
she uh
gets through this in the next few days
um we know that prince charles uh
recovered quite quickly from from
covid19 but here we are that the queen
testing positive after almost two years
of
coronavirus uh she has tested positive
for coving 19.
that's coming from buckingham palace